Hey everyone. I'm Chintan and I have my
colleague Daniel with me.
We are solutions architect on the AWS
APJ startup team.
So today we are going to talk about
something we've been working on for a
while.
Which is turn taking in voice agents.
What I mean by that is how does the
system actually know that you have
finished speaking and it's time for the
agent to respond?
These are all audio engineering
problems. They are not LLM problems
because
you can have the perfect model, perfect
track
but the experience still might feel
broken if the turn taking is off.
So we are going to walk you through the
concepts and three different approaches
to solving this.
And Daniel is going to you know make it
more concrete by running all the three
demo for you.
So to kick things off uh
we'll start with the 200 millisecond
constraint which is basically the
physics of why voice is hard.
Then we look into the pipeline
architecture, what are the components,
where turn taking actually lives.
We'll then look at three level of
solving this problem.
Going from simple silence detection all
the way up to running your own turn
detection model.
And then we'll also talk about the
latency, the budget and production
issues that we've seen.
So but before any of that, I just want
to show you the problem statement more
clearly because you have the same user.
You have the same sentence on the both
side but the
user outcome is very different because
on the left when the user says I want to
fly
and midway they try to correct
themselves, the agent just does not
notice.
Because it keeps going on for almost 2
seconds while the person is sitting
there trying to get a word in.
On the right side, the same exact
interaction is happening, but the agent
is able to capture the interruption in
under 200 milliseconds.
And immediately backs off so the user
can now speak.
Both the scenarios, the LLM was
identical. It was the same model. It was
the same prompt, but the difference in
the user experience is so different. And
the difference is purely because of the
audio pipeline.
And how fast does it notices like
someone else is talking and it knows
when to shut up. Like that's the problem
we're trying to solve today.
So, we'll cover this 200 millisecond
constraint because 200 milliseconds is
how fast humans switch turns with each
other in a conversation.
And the implications are pretty brutal
because at 800 milliseconds, things
start to feel off. While at 1.5 seconds,
your user just hang up on you because
you have like your HR chat agents might
get 5 seconds to respond and nobody will
care.
But with the voice agents, you don't get
that luxury.
We've seen recently like Salesforce was
able to pivot the pipeline and they
published their results in March 26th.
But even there, best measured response
time was 755 milliseconds. So, that's
like almost 4x slower than how
humans naturally take turns when
talking.
So, the question here becomes how do we
close this gap and where we cannot close
it like at least how do we get the turn
taking right?
So, the user experience does not feel as
bad as the raw numbers might suggest
here.
So, if you're working with a budget of
755 milliseconds and every millisecond
count,
you also need to understand what's
actually in the pipeline. Like where
does the time go and where does this
turn taking fit?
So, the pipeline itself you probably
might know the main components, the STT,
the LLM, the TTS.
You have the audio in, text out, text
in, audio out.
But the piece that's often missing like
from people
while people are thinking about this is
this voice activity detection.
Commonly called as VAD.
It's a tiny component that sits right at
the front and it is the one that
controls turn taking.
Its job is to basically detect whether
the user has stopped talking or not.
And the two other thing that you set
alongside main pipeline are also very
critical for turn taking.
So, you have the smart turn detection
which watches the VAD signal.
Plus the audio features and then it has
to make that decision that whether
should it respond now
or should it wait because the user might
still be talking.
And the interruption handler is
triggered when someone barges in.
So, what it'll do is it'll propagate a
flush of downstream like the TTS would
stop and the LLM generation need to be
canceled so that the pipeline is ready
for the new input within about, you
know, 50 ms.
So, if you remember I was talking about
like how there are different levels to,
you know, building this turn taking in
voice agents.
So, we'll start with a level one.
Level one is your Silero VAD. So, this
is a simple component which you fully
own and like a lot of production system
even today we see are running agents
just by using this.
So, coming to Silero VAD, it's a small
300,000
parameter model.
It takes in like a short term Fourier
transform. It has a
and it takes raw audio and it'll convert
it into a spectral features.
It has four convolutional layers
to pick up the pattern and an LSTM
that gives it memory so across the frame
so it's just not looking at one chunk in
isolation.
And then it has a sigmoid that gives a
probability of speech and it's like a
very small 2 megabyte model.
And the one parameter that minimum
silence millisecond is basically the
entire user experience of level one.
If you keep it very low, the agent is
going to be snapping like it will cut
people off while they're still, you
know, thinking.
But if you keep it very high, the agent
might become super patient and it will
never interrupt but you might get to
uh get like a dead air where people will
wonder if the agent is still connected
or not.
So there's like no universally right
answer. It depends on the domain. If
you're working on it from a perspective
of a sales agent, you probably want it
to be like 200 milliseconds.
If you're in a domain where you need
some to give some time to your user to
respond, it could be like 1
uh thousand to 1,200 milliseconds. It
depends entirely on what you're
building.
So VAD works well like that's why a lot
of people are using it and it's
generally good at what it does that is
to return fast response to the basic
question of whether there's someone
talking right now.
But uh there are things like it was
never designed to handle because
there'll be situations where just
knowing that is there a silence will not
be enough because
you also need to answer these questions
of how long to wait like uh the silence
duration.
If someone is pausing for 300
milliseconds or 400 milliseconds, VAD is
seeing the same exact thing.
It has no idea like whether the person
is catching up their breath or whether
they've completely finished their
thought.
So like they cannot distinguish that.
And the second scenario is like, what if
they, you know, the user talks over the
agent, like, it barges in.
It does not know how to handle it. And
the same silence can have a different
intent.
And it can be like completely different
things. It could be like a completed
sentence, it would be an incomplete
thought, it could be like a thinking
pause.
Or maybe it could be something as basic
as like a backchannel acknowledgement.
Uh the situation of the silence is same,
but the intent again was very different
in all the scenarios, but
VAD considers all four equally, and it
literally cannot tell them apart.
So, those are the limitation of level
one. And with the level two, basically
what you get is that you let the STT
service tell you like when the turn is
over.
So, Cartesiant does turn detection right
inside their STT websocket. So, when
they stream your audio in,
the server would handle both the
transcription and the turn detection
together, and it will emit event when it
thinks like the turn is done.
Similarly, Deepgram does the same thing
with their what they call as their I
think at the endpointing.
And their P50 latency for Cartesiant is
about 300, and it's about 250 for
Deepgram Nova 3.
Both of these are also working really
well. Like, we see a lot of customers
use that.
Because they are using like full audio
signals plus some linguistic context to
make these decisions. So, which is like
much more information than your VAD will
ever have.
However, the trade-off is with the
transparency. Because when it is
working, it works great. But when it
misfires, or when it cuts someone off at
the wrong moment, then you
like have no way to figure out because
there's no law that will say
uh it was done because of this reason,
because of the what was what it saw.
And that decision was made inside
someone else's server, and you just got
to live with that, basically.
So, that brings us to level three. So,
in level three, you keeps a little VAD
running locally for basic signal that is
there a speech.
And you add Smart Turn on top of it,
which is a small model that runs during
silence.
So, Smart Turn V3.2 is the latest model,
like, and uh
let me share some numbers with you. And
it has about 58.9%
recall and 68.4 percent precision.
So, what this means is that about six
out of 10 time when someone finishes a
sentence, Smart Turn will be able to
catch it quickly. But the other four
times, it might not be confident enough,
but that's also fine because
you still have your VAD timer, which is
running underneath as a safety net.
If the Smart Turn doesn't fire, your
stop second will kick in, like, at the
configured latency anyway. So, it could
be like 300 ms.
So, in that scenario, you are never
stuck waiting. You just, like, get the
fast respond when the model is
confident. And you get a slightly slower
but a safer respond when it's not.
The other number on this list is from,
like, a Meta's published paper earlier
this year, um around March.
There, they had reported a higher recall
at 87.7%,
but they haven't released the code, so
you really cannot deploy it.
Smart Turn is BSD-2 licensed, and it's a
8-MB
small model. You can pip install it
today as well. So, yeah, like, that
works out better for a lot of our
customers. We decide when to start
talking.
But like, what about the other
direction? What happens when the user
interrupts and
while you are already, you know, the
agent is talking?
So, on the left side, you can see what
happens mechanically. Like, user opens
you mouth, the windy will pick it up in
32 milliseconds and then then like 15
milliseconds, the entire pipeline is
flushed.
TTS stops, LLM cancels, everything is
clean. Like, the user never hears the
agent. You know, that part is taken care
by Pipe Cat.
But, the important thing is like, should
it have stopped there on because think
about a normal conversation when someone
says, "Yeah." Like, if they send an
acknowledgement while you're speaking,
you don't stop, right?
You know, they're just agreeing, but if
you they say like, "Okay, wait, no.
Like, that was wrong."
You have to stop immediately.
Same thing here. Like, the red is the
it's a correction.
Stop on everything. They amber could be
just some sort of a filler background
noise. But, you want to go ahead and
keep going, maybe in a bit quieter.
Blue means like a signal for cough for a
background noise. So, you can just
ignore it and finish your sentence.
So, at level three because you own this
classification, you can start
distinguishing between a real
interruption and someone just, you know,
going
um.
So, today most of these systems stop
every time, but this is a piece that's
improving. Like, we are seeing a lot of
incremental improvement in this.
So, by now that you've seen all three
levels and if you look at these three
Python files, pipeline is almost
identical in all of them.
The only thing that differs is how you
answer all of these questions. When is
the user done talking?
In file one, you pass in Celero VAD
analyzer and that says the user had been
silent for 300 milliseconds, so you can
assume they're done.
In file two, you swap it with the
Cadence turns STT service class and now
the service is going to tell you when
the turn is over.
And in file three, you keep your Celero
VAD analyzer, but you also add like a
local smart turn analyzer version three,
which is sort of a small model that runs
during your silence and it's going to
look at the prosody
and it's going to look at prosody and
intonation to decide whether that pause
meant I'm done or I'm still thinking.
So, you have the code-wise the same
pipeline, but the configuration changes,
which you know, leads to completely
different behavior.
So, to summarize your three levels,
where our level one was Celero VAD, so
you basically own the silence detection
completely.
Level two, you let the STT provider
handle it for you. And in most cases, it
it will speak smarter, but then you
cannot see what happened inside it.
Level three is your VAD plus smart turn,
so where we basically own everything,
like you have full portability.
And now coming to the latency piece,
because we've been throwing around these
numbers, 755 milliseconds, 1.3 seconds,
but let me show you where all the time
actually goes in.
So, this is a breakdown from Quintela,
who was a co-founder of Daily.co and is
the person who created Pipe Band. And
these are some of the numbers based on
their production measurement.
So, you have the numbers for making an
which is about 40 ms. Then you have
network and jitter buffer of 52.
So, these are physics. Like you can't
really change them much. Then you have
your transcription plus end pointing.
That's about 300 ms. Again, that's your
STT doing its thing.
LLM time to first byte, and this is
generally the dominant bottleneck
because in a typical API setup, you're
looking at 500 to 650 ms depending on
what model you're calling and from which
cloud provider, which region.
And then you have your network out and
playback
TTS. That's it's going to take about 120
to 90 85 ms.
So, you're totally looking at roughly
1,100 to 1,300 ms in a standard setup
calling cloud APIs.
Now, the Quindos team had demonstrated
about 500
ms total voice-to-voice by co-locating
all models in the same GPU cluster.
Because they were able to eliminate the
network hops within the service.
And it's sort of an achievable floor
because if you're willing to invest in
infrastructure, but for most of the
developers today calling APIs, you're
somewhere in the range of 800 to 1,300
ms.
And the key insight to note here is that
the STT, LLM,
together eat about 2/3 of the is
latency budget.
So, these are the really the only two
levers that we have to move this latency
metric needle in a meaningful manner.
So, coming to like which LLMs are
actually fast enough for this?
We benchmark current models specifically
for voice, and the target we kept it as
under 700 ms time to first token.
Because anything slower will push our
total response past where the user is
going to start noticing.
So, for now, like recording in June
2026,
what we've observed Nemotron-3 Ultra
gives us a 529 P50
latency.
GPT-4.1 at about 536.
But also, like what matters more in
voice uh
than P95.
So, which LLMs are actually fast enough
for this?
We benchmark current models, specially
uh for voice, and
So, coming to the So, coming to the LLMs
models, which are actually fast enough
for the
We benchmark current models well for
voice. Uh so, these benchmarks are from
June 26, and the target that we kept was
under 700 ms
for time to first open, because anything
slower
would push our total response time past
the limit, like where users is going to
start noticing.
So, for now, the Nemotron-3 Ultra at
529 P50,
we observed GPT-4.1 at 536, again P50.
But what matters more in voice than
maybe anywhere else is that the P95
tail. Because GPT-4.1
was great at P50,
but it spikes to 1.7 at P95.
And it was even worse for Claude 3 that
it hit over 4 seconds and because in a
conversation you cannot average this out
because one slow response and your
entire flow is gone.
And there's one more dimension that
people often miss, which is the
multi-turn trip because after 15 or 20
turn, sometime model starts ignoring
parts of the system prompt.
They might get to verbose, they go off
spirit.
Because in
that's fatal, you can't just dump a wall
of text on someone if the instruction
following degrades across turn.
Then you have to do some sort of a
context pruning or session resets.
So a few production issues that we've
seen
that
false interruptions significantly
increase your escalation rate.
Because when agents cut people off
incorrectly, then users are more likely
to request for a human in the loop uh
support.
And a 755 ms that's still I think the
best measured voice-to-voice for a
cascaded pipeline like the ones which we
propose.
We're nowhere near the human speed of
interaction, which means the return
taking also needs to do a lot of heavy
lifting to make the experience feel
better
than the raw numbers it would suggest.
And at 58.9%
recall on smart turn,
that's actually the best deployable turn
detection you can get today and because
although it still leaves like four out
of 10 turns
to be filled by a
uh VAD timer,
but this space is going to improve a lot
over the next year
few years and
uh we'll have better model.
And on infrastructure running all of
this in production is also hard because
five systems that all scale differently
and can also fail differently.
You can explore Picovoice Cloud for
managed hosting where your focus is on
agent logic or the AWS guidance
reference architecture for enterprise
deployments with all the enterprise
guardrails.
So yeah, like uh
Uh that's it from me. Everything uh
we've discussed or mentioned is linked
on the screen that I pulled benchmark.
Okay, over to you, Dan.
>> Thanks, Jinson. Hi, everyone. Uh my name
is Daniel Weijia. I'm also a solutions
architect with the AWS startups team.
So I think um Jinson walked you through
a great overview of some of the key
challenges when building voice agents.
So what I'm going to do in this session
is just to
walk you through a hands-on demo um just
to make the concepts a bit more
concrete. Um hopefully
um you can kind of
um incorporate some of the learnings
into your own voice agent pipelines as
well. So what we'll be going through is
just this
Picovoice Cat 10 detection demo, which
is just a simple repository that we've
created. Um we'll talk through three
examples. So one with um silence
detection, another with um
built-in 10 detection in the
speech-to-text model.
And then finally,
um we'll go through the open smart 10
model as well. So this is really useful
when
you either want full control of your um
voice pipeline just for from a
compliance perspective or if you want to
also fine-tune and customize your own 10
detection model based your own based on
your own data. So yeah, let's get
started. So let's just go through the
source code of the first example.
As you can see here, um using Silero is
pretty easy in Pipe Cat. All you have to
do is import the relevant libraries,
and you can configure the parameters as
well. Um I haven't actually
uh configured any of the parameters, so
these are just the default, but you can
change the parameters like the
confidence to trigger, the silence
duration before the turn ends, and the
minimum audio volume as well. And in
terms of the voice voice pipeline, it's
pretty standard. So, we've used um an
STT model, the LLM, and also a TTS model
here. We've just defined it as the
Cartesia model for STT. Same with the
Sonic model for TTS, and as you can see,
we've used the voice that sounds like a
a British lady.
And for the LLM in the voice agent's
brain, we've just used the Anthropic
Claude like cool model. So, we'll see
um
what that looks like, and I'll spin up
this example right now. So,
So, if you haven't used Pipe Cat before,
one of the nice things is that it can
spin up
a local prototyping environment. Really
useful for playing around with your
voice agent pipeline. So, let me just
see
if this now works. Okay. So, as you can
see, it will come up with a um local
uh development environment.
So, what I might do is just connect to
the voice agent, but before I do that, I
might just mute just in case
um
I'm interrupting the voice agent. It
should
come up with like an opening greeting,
and then I'll test it with some uh
interactions to see how the turn
detection is working.
>> Hey there, I'm your travel assistant and
I'm excited to help you plan an amazing
trip. So, where are you thinking of
going? Anywhere in the world you've got
your eye on?
>> As you can see, the assistant's
gone ahead to do the opening greeting
and on the right here in the terminal,
I've just got
um some real-time logs just so we can
see what's happening. So, what I might
do now is just I'm going to pretend that
I'm uh thinking about my travel
destination and see how the voice agent
behaves.
So, I'm thinking of going to um
>> I'm all ears. Where are you thinking of
heading?
>> As you can see, I haven't really
finished my
uh sentence yet, but the voice agent is
already responding. So, you can see how
this works in the debug logs and as you
can see, there's an end of turn complete
here
and the reason for that is due to the
stop seconds parameter, which is um set
to um
300 milliseconds, it looks like here.
So, that's why it's gone ahead and ended
the turn.
Um what I might do is I might just exit
this local server
and try the second example.
So, let's just clear that and I'll
refresh that. Okay, so I'm going to try
the second example here.
And in this example, we'll use a
um speech-to-text model which has turn
detection. So, we'll see how the voice
agent behaves.
Okay.
I'm going to try uh the same example, so
let me just mute myself here.
>> Hey there. I'm your travel assistant and
I'm excited to help you plan an amazing
trip. So, where are you thinking of
heading? Are you dreaming of a beach
getaway, a city adventure, mountains, or
maybe somewhere completely different?
>> All right, let's see how the model
behaves this time.
Hi, I'm thinking of going to
um
As you can see, the model is pretty
smart. It now can detect the turn, so
let's see if we can find out what's
going on
in the debug logs. So,
um let's see if it emits uh some of
those turn taking events here.
So, as you can see,
um the Katisha Inc. model does emit some
turn events here.
And as you can see, it hasn't really
completed the turn. It hasn't sort of
um
responded back with any response.
But, maybe I can unmute myself and then
resume and get to the destination. So,
Sydney?
>> Oh, Sydney is fantastic. You're going to
have such a great time there. Are you
thinking about when you'd like to go?
And how long are you planning to stay?
That'll help me figure out the best
flights and hotels for you.
>> So, as you can see, once the model
detects that it's a full complete
sentence, is able to then respond. Now,
in practice, you would also incorporate
um
some silence detection there because as
you can see, I was quite silent. Um I
was muted for a while and you'd probably
want the voice agent to respond in
practice.
Um having like voice uh activity
detection or silence detection is also
useful for
um interrupting the voice models um um
or what you call barge in as well. So,
definitely this is just a a quick demo,
but in practice, you would probably
combine both the turn detection model
and the silence detection.
Um just for the final demo, I might
quickly show the smart turn model as
well and see what that looks like. Um it
will behave very similar to to this.
It's just that um
the model will be running on your uh
either your local machine or um on a GPU
uh environment as well if you want to
deploy that into your into the cloud.
So, let me just maybe clear this just to
avoid confusion.
And then I'll use um I'll refresh this
as well.
And I'll start now the smart turn
example.
I'll refresh this
to see if we can Okay, there you go.
It's starting it. And I'm just going to
do the same example. So, I'll mute
myself again.
>> Hey there. I'm your travel assistant and
I'm excited to help you plan an amazing
trip. So, where are you thinking about
going? Are you dreaming of a beach
getaway, exploring a new city, or maybe
something else entirely?
>> I'm thinking of going to um
>> I'm all ears. Where are you thinking of
going?
>> Now, let's take a look at the um
both the silence detection, which is
incorporated into this example, and also
the turn detection model. Hopefully,
there are some
um debug logs that we can see.
As you can see, um
it's not detecting that I've completed
the turn. The end of turn state is
incomplete, but it did complete it um
due to the silence that I've um
I've
um
incurred there. Um so, that there was
some silence, and therefore it sort of
kept going with the
with the um next turn.
What I might do is see if I can do a
complete sentence and see if, you know,
um it can be detected through the local
smart turn model.
I'm actually thinking of um going to
Sydney.
>> Oh, Sydney's fantastic. I'd love to help
you plan that trip. So, tell me, what
time of year are you thinking about
going, and how long are you planning to
stay? Also, are you traveling solo, with
a partner, or with family?
>> Okay, fantastic. So, the voice agent was
able to respond as soon as I
uh completed the sentence, but let's see
if that was actually intentional, or was
that um
something that um you know, can be
detected through the smart turn model.
So, let's have a look here to see if we
can find the smart turn um debug logs.
As you can see,
this line here, I'm sorry about the
legibility of the highlight, but
effectively this here says that um the
end of turn state in is complete, and
the smart turn model is actually
classifying that there is a high
probability that that um the sentence is
complete and therefore it's okay to go
to the next turn. So that's
in a nutshell how turn detection works.
Hope that was helpful.